>> Growing signs of what
could be an increase inside
Russia, and Russian occupied
territory.
A moscow-backed official in the
city of --
was wounded by what appears to
be an explosive device in his
front yard.
Police chief was killed last
week that the Mueller incident
which Russia called, sabotage
by reconnaissance group.
A second question freight train
has derailed this week, in
Russia --
region.
The governor blames an
explosive device, and again no
one was killed in either
derailment.
In the meantime, the latest uk
intelligence shows Russian
forces have mailed what is
considered the most complex
extensive network of branches
in Europe since World War II.
Both southern Russia and
occupied Ukraine.
The defense ministry, says the
defense highlight Moscow's deep
concern that Ukraine could
achieve a major breakthrough
with its plan counter
offensive.
Joining me now from Washington
--
CNN military analyst Cedric
Leighton.
It has been a, while it is good
to see you.
>> Good to see you as, well
John.
>> So the trenches area
reflection of Russia's biggest
fear, then it seems safe to
assume that Rachel feels losing
crimea at the most given the
concentration of those
defensive fortifications.
Is that the line for Vladimir
Putin?
>> It does seem to be at least
one of his --
what he has been doing, John,
he has been actually moving
some forces into crimea, he is
actually putting defensive
positions up in places like --
which is a small town that is
critical point of approach.
Ukrainian forces to get close
to crimea, so this is one of
those key areas where Putin is
basically making a stand.
I think that would be a
make-or-break point at this
juncture.
>> There's also this reported
45 mile long mega trends around
zaporizhzhia.
The zaporizhzhia area far from
the front lines.
According to the uk defense
ministry, since summer 2022,
Russia has constructed some of
the most expensive systems of
military defensive networks
seen anywhere in the world for
decades.
These defenses are not just
near the current frontlines,
but also being dug deep inside
areas Russia currently
controls.
As a general rule, if you are
winning a war and victory is
within reach, is it usual to
stop and dig hundreds of miles
of changes behind your front
lines?
>> Not at all.
If you are --
basically taking an advantage
to the anomie, and trying to
out-the enemy with a --
this has been anything but it
mobile war in recent months.
What this shows is, not only
for war of attrition, but also
for the defense in case the
Ukrainian --
>> And all of this --
counteroffensive the --
Ukraine's interior minister has
said that eight storm brigades
comprising of 40,000 troops are
being reequipped as --
counteroffensive against
Moscow's invasion.
Apparently one of the big
factors here remains the
weather, we are now into may.
If this offensive --
have the Ukrainians had enough
time to prepare, as there been
enough time for training other
new weapons, tanks, armored,
vehicles, would you expect to
see the Ukrainian version of?
Well >> The one piece that
would be missing from a
campaign would be the
Ukrainians are asking for f-16s,
the f-16s will be highly
unlikely and anytime soon in,
Ukraine and this offensive,
however there are some weapons
coming into the latest arms
package to Ukraine which are
air to ground munitions and
those will of course be
employed by aircraft in Ukraine
already has.
>> As far as the training
though on the tanks, that will
be the key here for the
Ukrainians, and those tanks are
--
Russian tanks, how is that
going to play out?
>> I think that is going to
work out pretty well, because
--
challenger tanks and the
leopard tanks in Germany and
European countries, the
Ukrainians have had some time
to prepare themselves for these
tanks, and use them and deploy
them, and in a way that will
help them find maneuver.
So we could see a major tank
battle really take place here
in these two parts of Ukraine,
possibly the southern part of
Ukraine, that will be something
we haven't seen and that's part
of the world since the 1940s.
>> And finally, we have this
assessment by U.S. Intelligence,
100,000 Russian troops dead
since December.
That seems like an incredibly
high number.
The --
made up number, how do you say
it?
>> I don't think it is
completely made up, I think
this very heart of course to
estimated he troublesome of
casualties, but it doesn't ring
true to me that this number of
total casualties would be
pretty accurate given the
number that have died in places
like bakhmut and we are pretty
certain of, and also places
like --
which is also on the frontline.
It seems to be that the
Russians probably lost
somewhere between 20 and 25,000
dead, and 100,000 wounded or
otherwise combat --
>> That and wounded, great